being human is always directed and
pointing to something other than itself
he had been blessed with a gifted mind
he didn't fit into any conventional
sense into anything life in principle
never ceases to hold a meaning for each
and every trust to the American public
though he's best known to his book man's
search for meaning but as so far sold
over a million copies alone in this
country a genius with the simplest of
tastes he was almost like a child and
his purposes were always therapeutical I
felt the exact same way when I lay in
that hospital bed as he did when he was
in a concentration camp y me dijo ESO
fue la casa de mis padres de la que yo
sali y nunca mas body he didn't get
fixated on the past and wanted to build
who was the future the barriers between
people and religious groups were
irrelevant to him he was sorry for them
decency new bodies to be helpful the
school sesli gay not shown for a las
vegas it didn't sit well in many circles
he doesn't get the recognition he
deserves because he never cared that
nobody is capable of fully understanding
dr. Frankel
what he endured
anyone who wants to know what does it
take to create change in short periods
of time you got to look around and you
got to say there's only a few people
that Mabel consistently do that produce
those results and Erickson's one of them
he was profoundly aware of the shifts of
consciousness of people here was almost
like magic the stories about his
perceptiveness or legendary person named
nine trains is not anatomical and he can
do what he chooses better than he can no
waking state with a lightning flash of
the wrists he threw the stone directly
at me and he said why would you want to
see yourself sitting over there in that
chair that's all he needed to do you
didn't believe he was psychic but he
seems like sometimes I was five when he
had infantile paralysis they tell his
mother the boys gonna die tonight
sometimes I'd feel gosh I wish he would
just be ordinary and say have a nice day
they did not understand we call his
genius
because he was so different the security
became amplified compared to which most
of us are deaf nothing fight a lot of
people call him the crazy man out of
Phoenix he helped j edgar hoover and we
got a letter from him he went further
than what i would choose today i was
really happy for the first time in my
life he looked at me and he said the the
way you see it there's not the way they
you